the death toll from the corona virus has
now topped 102 thousand in this country
there have been more than 1.7 million
known cases in the US we have learned
some popular Florida tourist
destinations such as Universal Orlando
plan to start reopening its hotels as
soon as Tuesday at the same time the
economy witnessed a nearly 14% drop in
consumer spending last month Tom Hansen
is here in New York where reopening
plans are starting to take shape Tom
good morning good morning Jeff while New
York and New Jersey account for about
40% of all of the deaths due to
coronavirus in the United States and now
a new study says that as many as 2
million New Yorkers may have been
infected by the end of March far more
than previously reported
New York's reopening is not without
limits in select upstate regions offices
and hair salons will reopen but it's not
just open the doors and everybody has a
party it's 50% occupancy in office
buildings Governor Andrew Cuomo will
also let business owners deny entry to
anyone not wearing a mask that store
owner has a right to protect themselves
still shut down New York City is
expected to start the first phase of
reopening next week we're going to be
providing face coverings for free for
all businesses that need them
the city's 27,000 restaurants though
will stay closed
Angelina Miller ba' owns Angelina's
Ristorante
anything we don't know June July August
wet with cases on the rise in Los
Angeles barbershops Hair Salons and
restaurants can now do business in
Northern California where the impact of
the virus was significantly lower
graduations along with mall shopping are
taking place in parking lots also it's
good if you do want your things right
away same day or the next day so you
don't have to wait for it to be shipped
even the Grand Canyon opened up to
sightseers on its popular South Rim at
the White House coronavirus task force
coordinator dr. deborah birx touted
progress friday to business leaders new
hospitalizations are down month over
month by 50% mortality the fatalities
that we grieve are down significantly
week over week though in real numbers
there were more than one hundred and
thirty-nine thousand eight hundred and
seventeen new confirmed cases and six
thousand new deaths this week and 24
states reported increases in their
average new kovat 19 cases compared to
two weeks ago Alabama had more than
5,000 new positive cases in the 14 day
period ending Thursday and meat
processors continued to report bad news
a Tyson pork plan in Iowa became the
latest to halt operations more than 500
of its 2,500 workers tested positive
into a facility that they may get the
virus they may die they may bring it
home with them and of course many of us
saw that shocking video of partiers
packed into a pool at Lake of the Ozarks
in Missouri over Memorial Day weekend
well CBS News has now learned that at
least one person tested positive for
coronavirus who was at that party which
is exactly what health officials were
trying to avoid Jeff Tom thank you very
much